How do things move in real life?
Say a ball is moving on a flat ground,
and there is no external force acting on it.
Will the ball eventually come to a halt?
Yes, it will. Have you ever wondered why?
Say you're skating on an ice rink
and your friend is skating on the road.
Whose movement do you think will be smoother?
Definitely yours!
When you hold a bottle in your hand,
why doesn't it just slip through and fall?
Sometimes when you're walking around in a mall,
do you remember seeing a caution sign to warn you
about the floor being wet?
What explains all this?
The answer is FRICTION!
The reason why the ball eventually comes to a halt
is because of the force of friction.
The reason why skating on an ice rink is easier
because the force of Friction is lesser there.
The bottle doesn't slip through
because the force of friction between your hand and the bottle
doesn't allow it to do so.
If the floor is wet the friction offered by it reduces
and there are chances that you might slip and fall.
So what is this friction that we're talking about?
It's quite easy to understand its concept.
Friction is nothing but a FORCE.
It is the force exerted by a surface where an object moves across it.
In the first case, when the ball is moving in this direction,
the force of friction is acting in the opposite direction.
The force of friction offered by the ice rink floor
is lesser than the force of friction offered by the road.
Hence skating on the ice rink is easier and seems effortless!
The bottle does not slip down
because the surface of your hand offers a friction in the upward direction.
And in the case of the floor in the mall,
the soapy water reduces the friction offered by the floor.
In the coming lessons, we'll learn a lot more about friction.
We'll see the factors affecting friction.
We'll understand if friction helps us in our everyday life or not.
And we will also cover the different types of friction.